ils étaient environ 200 selon les
organisateurs une centaine selon la
gendarmerie
des agriculteurs répondant à l'appel de
deux syndicats sont venus manifester
jeudi soir dernier devant l'abattoir de
houdan accompagné de quelques élus
locaux ils dénoncent les agissements de
l'association l214 qui a déposé plainte
contre cet établissement pour
maltraitance animale
ça a démarré d'un père de famille dont
son fils travaille ici qui m'a dit mais
si l'abattoir y faire mon fils il va
être au chômage comment comment je
commence enfin voila c'est normal qu'un
père s'inquiète de savoir comment on
veut son fils va finir les fins de mois
les traites de sa maison et des choses
comme ça il y à une quinzaine de jours
l'association l214 diffusé des images
filmées à l'intérieur de l'abattoir
montrant des employés en train de
distribuer des coups aux cochons pour
forcer leur passage vers l'abattage les
images l214 qui monde et vêtir
effectivement choquer tout a été fait
chez nous pour que ça se reproduise plus
tout était déjà fait mais là on a mis
les bouchées doubles des promesses qui
ne suffiront pas l'association l214 a
annoncé un nouveau rassemblement de
protestation devant l'abattoir jeudi
prochain je ne peux pas tolérer c'est
qu'un groupe qui a une philosophie
particulière qui est de choisir de ne
pas consommer aucun produit d'origine
animale puisse diriger en une sorte de
diktat ou imposer cette volonté à
l'ensemble de la société
l'entreprise avait rencontré des
difficultés au début des années 2000
suite à la crise de la vache folle
elle avait ensuite remonté la pente en
pariant sur le circuit court prisés par
les consommateurs